gnadenlos heute ist mir gar nichts übrig
ich habe noch im Kühlschrank voll viel
Buttercreme
also den kriegst schon eine riesen
Buttercremetorte
ich ja Samiras oh mist
ich hab grad vergessen war für die Torte
backt stimmt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute ist es soweit Samira ist schon 12
Jahre alt und bekommt ihre 12
Geburtstagstorte ein Jahr hatte ich mal
ausgesetzt muss ich sagen ein in einem
Jahr war es so dass ich die
Geburtstagstorte nicht hinbekommen habe
die ist einfach zerlaufen ja es war
glaube ich ihr Neunter oder ihr Achter
Geburtstag da waren wir alles sehr
traurig und ich habe das Video nie
ausgestrahlt weil ich sehr traurig
darüber war dass ich meiner Tochter
diese ach egal egal wir reden nicht
drüber da gab es nämlich so ein Trip den
mir den nicht ausprobieren sollte und
dann hat er nicht geklappt und dann sind
alle Sahnetupfer die ganze Zeit einer
von der Torte gerutscht über Nacht und
dann habe ich nie ausgestrahlt
jedenfalls gibt es heute eine
hoffentlich schöne Torte
Samira ist jetzt 12 und sie ist in so
einem Alter Schokocreme geht immer
schokoladentorten gehen auch immer und
ich habe jetzt hier auch schon vier
Böden vorgebacken und zwar ist es mein
mantelteig da gibt es einen Grundrezept
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier einfach die
Eier mit dem Zucker und Salz richtig
cremig verrührt habe Buttermilch und Öl
dazu gegeben die Zutaten nur ganz kurz
eingerührt und dann kommt schon die
Mehlmischung dazu also mehl mit
Backpulver und Kakao wird untergehoben
dann auf vier backringe vorbereitet bzw
verteilt und dann im Ofen gebacken das
ganze habe ich jetzt schon gestern
zubereitet sodass einfach die Böden
schön kalt sind ich habe sie über Nacht
abgedeckt dann den Kühlschrank gestellt
und jetzt sind sie eben schon fertig und
ich habe das ganze in Ferien gemacht
damit die Backzeit einfach etwas kürzer
ist und ihr könnt aber auch ganz gerne
den Teig in zwei Backring Backen zweimal
20 cm dann müsste einfach die
Kuchenböden etwas länger backen das
war's schon jetzt natürlich eine
Buttercreme her und weil ich die Torte
später weiß und Mint gestalten möchte
also mintfarben mache ich jetzt eine
Swiss Mering Buttercreme also mit Eiweiß
und hier gibt es auch schon einen
Grundrezept auf meinem Kanal und zwar
sollte das Eiweiß dadurch pasteurisiert
werden entweder mit dem heißen Wasserbad
oder in der Kenwood COOKING CHEF ich
mache das jetzt gleich hier aber wie
gesagt auf dem Wasserbad geht es
natürlich auch für die Swiss Buttercreme
verwende ich 140 g Eiweiß eine Prise
Salz 245 g Zucker 410 g weiche Butter
100 g Puderzucker und etwas
Vanilleextrakt ihr nimmt nämlich das
Eiweiß dann Zucker und Salz das ganze
kommt in die Rührschüssel oder über das
heiße Wasserbad und muss 10 Minuten lang
erwärmt werden über dem kochenden Wasser
am besten mit dem Handrührgerät oder
hier einfach in der Kenwood bei 70 Grad
nach 10 Minuten rühren nehmt ihr dann
die Hitze herunter also entweder bei der
Kenwood dann auf null Grad stellen und
weiterrühren oder das ganze vom
Wasserbad herunternehmen und in der
Küchenmaschine oder zum Beispiel mit dem
Handrührgerät schön karlsrühren das habe
ich jetzt gemacht das dauert auch so
etwa 10 bis 15 Minuten wichtig ist dass
die Eiermasse wirklich abgekühlt ist so
sieht sie aus richtig richtig schön und
diese Buttercreme mag ich auch sehr
gerne weil sie später auch eine schöne
helle Farbe hat ihr könnt aber auch
gerne eine französische Buttercreme
machen aber die wird mit ganzen Eiern
gemacht also auch Eigelb und dann hat
man halt so ein Gelbstich und ich will
später eine schöne weiße Creme haben
okay wie gesagt wichtig dass die jetzt
schön abgekühlt ist damit gleich die
Butter nicht schmilzt und jetzt könnt
ihr die Butter nehmen Puderzucker und
Vanilleextrakt und diese richtig schön
cremig rühren das ist auch sehr wichtig
weiß cremig rühren damit die Butter
schön luftig geschlagen wird und cremig
ist und eben später nicht so gelbstichig
und wo trägt
gelbstichig aussieht und Patrick
schmeckt sowas richtig
generell generell frage ich mich aber
echt schon viele Grundrezepte und dann
frage ich mich soll ich euch in solchen
Videos
trotzdem den Teig und die Creme und so
weiter zeigen oder interessiert euch
dann mehr wie die Torte gefüllt und
dekoriert wird und ich weise dann auf
die Grundrezepte hin das wäre sowas was
ihr vielleicht mal in den Kommentaren
gerne abstimmen dürft
[Musik]
so sieht die Buttermasse jetzt aus und
jetzt nehmt ihr einfach nur die
Eiweißmasse und rührt sie hier auch noch
schön ein und dann habt ihr eine schöne
luftige leckere Creme
[Musik]
jetzt die Buttercreme fertig die sieht
super aus so ist die Konsistenz ich
liebe einfach Buttercreme ich verstehe
es nicht wie man buttercremig
dann stelle ich jetzt die Maschine zur
Seite die Buttercreme zur Seite habe
hier die Böden und werde sie noch ein
bisschen gleichmäßig schneiden mit einer
tortensäge und dann kann die Torte schon
gefüllt werden
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier gerade noch einen
Fruchtaufstrich erwärmt Fruchtaufstrich
Erdbeere und jetzt weil es ja auch eine
Oreo Torte wird wow ich weiß es ist
immer so laut
Torte wird
kommen jetzt auch eure Kekse rein kommt
die Kids die feiern das doch oder
gut dann hacken wir die mal klein die
Oreos ich meine Keks ist halt echt nur
so Schokolade Vanille und viele finden
ja auch dass der künstlich schmeckt aber
trotzdem halten den alle also ich
verstehe das nicht so ganz seid ihr Oreo
ja oder Oreo nein ich finde dich mags
muss ich sagen
zur Seite
hier ist eine Tortenplatte
Antirutschmatte und der erste
Tortenboden den bestreiche ich jetzt mit
Marmelade bzw Fruchtaufstrich
jetzt einfach kurz mit allen
da kann es nämlich schon mal ein
bisschen einziehen
und ich glaube sind nicht besser man
drückt so ein bisschen mit der Palette
rein da geht es so richtig tief in die
Power
[Musik]
okay dann habe ich jetzt hier die
Buttercreme in einem Spritzbeutel mit
einer großen Lochtülle und damit könnt
ihr die Creme hier schön aufspritzen
eine schöne dünne Schicht
euch schön
die nächste Tour
so wird die Nicolette ihre Etikette Tour
machen wir eine back Tour
und jetzt eine kleine Umrandung
und hier innen kommen Kekse rein und da
ich vier Böden habe teile ich die Kekse
durch 3
oh ich hätte den
kommen könnte und dann einfach so eine
Torte bewertet
[Musik]
guck mal hier schön die Oreos
the nice dann kommt der nächste Boden
drauf und so füllt ihr jetzt die gesamte
Torte und ganz oben mache ich so dass
ich die Marmeladenseite wie beim
Butterbrot Butter Marmeladenbrot wenn es
runter fällst immer die Marmeladenseite
drehen wir das ganze um damit die Torte
dann schön glatt ist
[Musik]
stell die Torte jetzt in den Kühlschrank
ich stecke sie aber vorher ab mit
tortenrandfolie Tortenring drumherum da
kommt es erstmal in den Kühlschrank für
eine Stunde die Buttercreme lasse ich
bei Raumtemperatur aus dem Rest
Kuchenteig kann ich später kleine
Kügelchen noch machen dann habe ich da
auch noch eine kleine süße Leckerei ich
berühre sowas immer gerne mit Sahne mit
Quark oder Frischkäse und dann könnt ihr
Kokosraspeln dazugeben ihr könnt Likör
dazu geben alles was ihr möchtet und
später einfach in Kakao oder kokoswalzen
perfekt ist immer eine tolle
Resteverwertung und die Torte stell dir
stelle ich jetzt eine Stunde kühl dann
ist es schön fest und ich kann sie
perfekt glatt
[Musik]
dann geht sie jetzt mit der Torte hier
mal weiter die Folie die wasche ich
übrigens immer wieder ab die ist nämlich
wiederverwendbar
perfekt jetzt geht es darum dass die
Torte schön glatt und gerade wird und
hier ist jetzt wichtig weil ich so eine
neue Technik ausprobieren will das am
Rand später genug Creme dran kommt
deswegen nehme ich jetzt meine ganaching
Boards und ihr seht es jetzt hier auch
schon wenn ich es drauf lege dass die
Ganache Geburts größer sind als die
Springform Böden und diesen nehme ich
aufeinander abgestimmt damit man in den
Springform Böden die Böden backen kann
die sind ein bisschen kleiner als 20 cm
die ganachingboard sind eben perfekt 20
cm groß und dann könnt ihr nämlich damit
die Torten perfekt glatt streichen
ohne viel Aufwand
das machen wir jetzt erstmal so
dass mir das da nicht runter rutscht
klebe ich das jetzt hier mal an
wobei ich mache erstmal noch kurz eine
krümelschicht erstmal kurz hier die
Krümelchen anbinden dass da keine Krümel
am Rand sind also einmal kurz wow
einmal ein bisschen Creme aufstreichen
und eine dünne Schicht verstreichen
der Rest kommt dann der Rest kommt dann
auf die Oberfläche
dann kommt die Ganache drauf und da
achtet jetzt einfach nur drauf dass sie
wirklich perfekt übereinander liegen
denn ich will gleich keine Schokocreme
auf der Buttercreme
die mache ich auch kurz sauber
und dann könnt ihr jetzt alles was hier
quasi frei ist mit der restlichen
Buttercreme auffüllen
[Musik]
gut aber das passt jetzt ganz gut denn
die Torte kann jetzt eh mal in den
Kühlschrank und alles was hier noch
fehlt fülle ich dann gleich mit der
frischen Buttercreme auf
Koch sowieso noch was für die Deko ich
kratz gerade alle Reste zusammen die
Buttercreme muss jetzt reichen denn ich
muss gleich ein Muster reinziehen
[Musik]
sie wird reichen
ich würde mal sagen Leben am Limiter
[Musik]
auf die Platte
dann muss die obere Ganache
[Musik]
die Oberfläche ist jetzt erstmal egal
wichtig ist jetzt der Rand
dann nehme ich jetzt hier diese
Teigkarte die hat hier diese Ecken und
dann versuche ich und ich hoffe es
klappt alles die jetzt anzusetzen und zu
ziehen so dass Rillen in der Torte
entstehen
[Musik]
die Creme hier schön aufheben die
brauchen wir gleich noch
jetzt einfach schön abziehen ist eine
schöne Rille entsteht
[Musik]
jeder kleine Buttercreme Rest für Samira
zum Geburtstagsfest
dann habe ich jetzt hier noch Rest
Buttercreme und ich habe auch noch
bisschen was im Kühlschrank und da kommt
jetzt Farbe dazu ihr könnt das ganze
aber auch gerne mit Schoko Vanille
machen also hier ist Kakao oder eben
flüssige Schokolade dazugeben aber ich
glaube ich mache so ein bisschen
mintgrün
immer ganz wenig Farbe erstmal bisschen
Grün bisschen blau
Anna das ist kein Farbe das ist
Zuckerschrift
[Musik]
es ist kein mintgrün aber ich finde den
Ton eigentlich ganz hübsch
okay also man hätte auch eine größere
Schüssel nehmen können
aber nicht müssen
wer kann da haben
zum ersten Mal ich habe jetzt hier eine
Lochtülle die ist etwas kleiner die hat
7 mm und
jetzt muss diese Farbe in die Rillen
[Musik]
jetzt werden wir gleich sehen ob es
funktioniert hat ihr nehmt euch jetzt
eine Teigkarte am besten eine große die
Höhe ist als die Torte und jetzt einfach
schön abziehen
[Musik]
dann ist jetzt die Torte wieder gut
gekühlt
und ich setze sie jetzt schon mal auf
meine Tortenplatte
[Musik]
die stelle ich jetzt ganz kurz in den
Kühlschrank und werde jetzt hier schon
meine Ganache herstellen denn das wird
der Schokoladen drip aus 90 Gramm Sahne
10 g Kokosöl und 100 g
Zartbitterschokolade die Sahne wird
jetzt einfach mit dem Kokosöl aufgekocht
dann vom Herd runter genommen und dann
rühre ich die Schokolade ein bis alles
geschmolzen ist
weil ich das schon mal in eine drip
Flasche ihr könnt es aber auch mit einem
Löffel einfach auftragen
aber mit der Flasche kann man es etwas
besser dosieren und dann habe ich noch
ein paar Euro Kekse die restliche
Buttercreme die habe ich hier bereits in
einem Spritzbeutel mit einer großen
blütentülle
und dann hole ich noch ein paar Streusel
und ich denke damit komme ich ganz gut
aus
am besten probiert ihr den Trip immer
auf der Rückseite erstmal aus jetzt muss
erstmal gucken welche Seite ist nicht
die schöne schön schön schön
okay die hat keine Rückseite aber immer
am besten auf der Rückseite ausprobieren
und da die Torte ja kalt ist
sollte die Ganache auf der Torte auch
schön fest werden ohne dass sie so zu
sehr runterschropft falls du noch zu arg
tropft und zu warm ist lasst es einfach
nur ein bisschen abkühlen
[Musik]
dann nehme ich mir einen Tortenring ihr
könnt aber auch zum Beispiel einen
Teller oder was anderes rundes nehmen so
ein bisschen als Markierung
jetzt habe ich hier noch Rest
Buttercreme
und versuche jetzt schöne hohe Tupfen zu
spritzen
[Musik]
die Markierung dient dazu dass man eben
einen schönen Ring hinbekommt
[Musik]
die Mitte hier oben wird es auch noch
ausgefüllt
[Musik]
die kommen jetzt noch mal in den
Kühlschrank und dann
gefällt mir richtig gut
[Musik]
jetzt kann man hier noch
Geburtstagskerzen drauf
da kommst du laufen
mit zwei
Farben sind der Kindergarten
5 6 was in der Regelgruppe
7 das war die Einschulung
die 11 war die weiterführende Schule und
und ab dem nächsten Jahr sind Teenager
ich gehe kurz rein
so dann will ich jetzt mal sagen hier
Samira Tolga alle die da sind Jutta
wollt ihr noch zum Singen kommen
[Musik]
happy birthday to you
happy Birthday Liebe Samira happy
birthday to you
Geburtstag viel Glück zum Geburtstag
viel Glück zum Geburtstag alles Gute
zum Geburtstag viel Glück
Stück hoch soll sie leben hoch soll sie
leben
dreimal hoch
wenn ich jetzt schon zu den peinlichen
Mamas schon vor zwei Jahren ungefähr
echt jetzt seit zwei Jahren
darf ich das Mikrofon weiterhin benutzen
[Musik]
alles Gute mein Schatz danke schön
okay dann wünscht dir was
ich überlege gerade okay ich weiß es
nicht
ja
die Geburt auch zusammengeschafft vor 12
Jahren
okay los jetzt 1 2 3
okay wir schneiden es jetzt an aber wir
gucken nur rein okay wir machen uns
jetzt nämlich so dass wir weil der
Morgen deine Geburtstagsfeier ist wir
schneiden Sie nur an gucken kurz rein
und dann machen wir später
[Gelächter]
probieren könnt aber ich meine das
verkratzt
[Musik]
es Messer sauber machen
an wie findest du eigentlich die Torte
Option ja gefällt dir gefällt dir die
Optik
ist es eine coole Torte für zwölfjährige
passt es
toll gerade machen
ja ich liebe es
[Musik]
ruhig drin
drauf
hin und dann darfst du die morgen
probieren
sehr gut sieht schon cool aus oder
anschnallt gell echt mega cool geworden
ja super also wenn sie dir gefällt dann
ist meine Mission erfüllt tschüss bis
zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]